we recorded something very weird
something amazing something that
absolutely blew our minds and so we're
making a video that is different for us
and the fact that it happens over the
course of 20 minutes is absolutely
astonishing it is a very brief amount of
time but it also means that we have paid
the possibly incorrect decision of
sharing it with you
unedited and in real time it's just so
cool that we couldn't bring ourselves to
edit it we didn't want to speed it up we
wanted to take its course over the
amount of time that it took in the real
world but of course we also don't have
enough to say to fill up 20 minutes of
video so the narration will be coming in
and out as the event progresses if you
don't have a full 20 minutes to watch it
we have put the time codes of those
narrations in the description you can
click on them and go to the moment in
the video where I will be talking about
what's happening
so to begin Daphnia are a type of
crustacean they're known for the way
that they seem to jump while they swim
and one day about a year ago coming from
a cold pond in winter a Daphnia laid an
egg that eventually made its way under
our microscope that large dark oval you
see there taking up the upper-left
corner of the screen that is the daphne
egg but we're not really going to talk
about Daphnia today because as
previously mentioned things got weird at
the bottom corner there you can see that
the egg is leaking if you know nothing
about the reproductive habits of water
fleas and it's totally understandable if
you don't there's a sense of order to
that movement that might make it seem
innocuous the slow movement from one
oval to another
the leaking substance becomes enveloped
in a membrane it looks at least
intentional but James our master of
microscopes has spent hours every day
looking at the samples he collects and
when he saw this he knew something very
strange was going on he just didn't know
what so he did the obvious thing and hit
record
so watch with us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay is it done did it do the thing
there's something vaguely intestinal
about what we're watching here like the
egg is evacuating a part of it oh no
there's more it's still coming okay this
is it that is the last bit of whatever
the goop was it has transferred itself
out of the egg and into this brown
blobby thing
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay over the last few minutes our Miss
shapen blob took on a more definite
spherical shape also whatever came out
of the Daphnia egg appears to be well
and truly alive and as James changes
focus we can see that this larger sphere
appears to contain not just goop but
smaller spheres bound together by that
enclosing membrane they're jiggling
they're moving they're alive they are
cells
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now this started to seem like something
we might understand this egg it seems
was infected with something and that
something had succeeded it was an
intruder that having got what it needed
from its host was moving on to the next
phase of its lifecycle
and while the bulk of this image might
consist of the Daphnia egg what we're
actually launching the leaking the cell
forming the swimming is the reproduction
of a parasite
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it took months of searching but we later
learned that this parasitic species is
some type of OMI seat which if you know
your science Greek you will recognize as
a egg fungus and now it's actually not a
fungi but it does behave like a fungus
in many ways and OMI seeds are
responsible for some of the most harmful
plant pathogens including the one
responsible for much of the Irish potato
famine they're most closely related to
algae but they aren't really very
closely related to anything and the
cells inside the membrane are zua spores
from they have flagella and the membrane
is called the sporangium but the OMI
seat is still done here and the
strangest part is yet to come
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
in its own creeping way the bundle here
looks like it's expanding as the zua
spores inside swim more freely and
energetically they collide against each
other taking up more and more space like
a gas heating up eventually we imagine
they're going to take up so much space
that the sporangia m-- will rip apart
but not yet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now the pack of zua spores is getting
bigger their movements look almost
frantic pushing and pushing against the
sporangium
they're waving their flagella triggered
by some stimulus bouncing off of each
other straining the membrane the
sporangium is getting larger and larger
and then one zua spore breaks away the
membrane though invisible has now
definitely broken and it peels back and
all of its zua spore friends begin to
follow each of them searching for a new
host
each with the potential of starting this
whole process all over again to the
definite detriment of the next
generation of Daphnia that was wild
[Music]
of course we wish we could have captured
more of the beginning of this process
but from the completion of the
evacuation from the egg to release of
the sporangium was less than twenty
minutes in real time it's hard to be on
the side of these little parasites but
that doesn't mean they aren't
fascinating thank you for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the unseen
world that surrounds us
sometimes apparently we're gonna do it
in slightly different ways we're gonna
let what happens on the other end of the
microscope dictate what we do here on
this channel and we hope you are ok with
that if you are you are welcome to join
the community of people who helps us
make these videos including all of the
names that are on this screen right now
thank you for joining our patreon if you
want to see more from our master of
microscopes James check out Jam and
germs on Instagram and if you want to
see more of what we're up to there is
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby